mehr mut zur veränderung kanzlerin
merkel fordert in ihrer
neujahrsansprache einen stärkeren kampf
gegen den klimawandel
sturm auf amerikanische botschaft im
irak der streit zwischen dem us militär
und schiitischen milizen eskaliert start
ins neue jahr
einige länder haben 2020 bereits begrüßt
bei uns steigt die größte party am
brandenburger tor in berlin
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend und willkommen
zur letzten heute sendung des jahres
2019 christin ist auch dabei und sagt
was sportlich los genau im skispringen
und guten abend zum jahreswechsel meldet
sich die bundeskanzlerin traditionsgemäß
zu wort und ruft in ihrer
neujahrsansprache dazu auf
zuversichtlich und offen für neues zu
sein
nur dann seien veränderungen zum guten
möglich und sie dankte jenen die sich in
polizei und feuerwehr oder in der
kommunalpolitik für unser gemeinwesen
einsetzen sie vor allem müsse der staat
vor anfeindungen hass und gewalt
schützen frank buchwald mut machen in
unsicheren zeiten
angela merkels neujahrsansprache beginnt
ernst und hoffnungsvoll wir haben gute
gründe zuversichtlich zu sein dass sie
in wenigen stunden beginnen den 20er
jahre des einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts
gute jahre werden können im kommenden
jahr sei deutschland 30 jahre vereinigt
eine zeit in der die menschen
großartiges geleistet hätten
so hatten zum beispiel noch nie so viele
menschen arbeit wie heute dennoch bleibt
auch im nächsten jahrzehnt noch mehr zu
tun als wir vor 30 jahren gedacht haben
zentrale herausforderung der klimawandel
deutschland müsse alles menschenmögliche
tun um ihn zu bewältigen
sie wisse dass die beschlossenen gesetze
vielen menschen auch sorge bereiteten
vor allem kinder und enkel aber müssten
mit den folgen dessen leben was politik
heute tun oder unterlassen
deshalb setze ich all meine kraft dafür
ein dass deutschland seinen beitrag
leistet ökologisch ökonomisch sozial den
klimawandel in den griff zu bekommen
deutschen soldaten im ausland dank die
kanzlerin für ihren einsatz ebenso
polizei und feuerwehr aber auch
kommunalpolitikern sie wie alle menschen
in unserem land vor hass anfeindungen
und gewalt vor rassismus und
antisemitismus zu schützen ist aufgabe
des staates klare worte auch zum thema
migration hilfe für afrika liege im
interesse europas
nur wenn menschen die chance auf ein
friedliches und sicheres leben haben
flucht und migration abnehmen
veränderungen zum guten seien möglich
sagte merkel wenn menschen sich offen
und entschlossen auf neues einließen und
sie können die ansprache der
bundeskanzlerin bei uns gleich im
anschluss an diese nachrichten sehen
seit september letzten jahres gibt es
das staatliche baukindergeld und das
stößt auf reges interesse
bis ende november seien gut 170 tausend
anträge eingegangen berichtet die
rheinische post und beruft sich auf die
zuständige förderbank kfw
das entspreche zuschüssen von rund 3,5
milliarden euro
insgesamt stehen für das förderprogramm
knapp zehn milliarden euro zur verfügung
es läuft noch bis ende 2020 ins ausland
in der irakischen hauptstadt bagdad
haben hunderte wütende demonstranten
versucht die us botschaft zu stürmen als
reaktion auf die luftangriffe der usa
aufstellungen einer schiitischen miliz
die demonstranten attackierten die
außenmauern der botschaft und legten
feuer
es war ihnen gelungen in die sogenannte
grüne zone einzudringen das
hochgesicherte regierungs und
diplomatenviertel der us botschafter
wurde in sicherheit gebracht jürgen kehl
berichtet die grüne zone in bagdad
eigentlich ein hochsicherheitsbereich
gestürmt hunderte zornige demonstranten
werden durch nichts und niemandem
aufgehalten
erst die mauern der us-botschaft stoppen
die menge brandsätze und steine fliegen
wir bringen das feuer wir wollen die
amerikaner hier rausschmeißen
wir wollen sie treffen wir wollen sie
bestrafen amerikaner wir haben euch
gewarnt
auslöser der wut diese angriffe
amerikanischer jets aufstellungen
schiitische milizen gestern 24 kämpfer
starben vergeltung für den tod eines
us-amerikaners us marines schützen die
botschaft von tränengasgranaten
klar ist dass sturm des geländes ist
organisiert embleme schiitische milizen
die vom iran unterstützt werden sind zu
sehen
diese botschaft ist ein ort der
verschwörung gegen den irak ihre die
sabotage gegen den irak organisiert und
unsere souveränität untergraben
us-präsident trump meldet sich per
twitter iran zieht die fäden für den
angriff auf die amerikanische botschaft
im irak dafür tragen sie die volle
verantwortung wir erwarten dass der irak
mit seinen truppen die us-botschaft
schützt vor der botschaft dürfen sich
die demonstranten austoben erst spät
schickt die regierung truppen zum schutz
der amerikaner iran hat mit seinen
milizen im irak ein zeichen der stärke
gesetzt
wir haben eine zuspitzung der lage
zwischen iran und den usa in erster
linie die aber ausgetragen wird in
anderen ländern zunächst im irak
möglicherweise aber auch in den nächsten
tagen und wochen wieder in syrien und im
libanon
die usa als gemeinsamer feind der iran
nutzt auch im irak alte muster um die
güterstraße für sich zu nutzen
im südosten australiens spitzt sich die
feuer krise dramatisch zu tausende
menschen sind von den buschbränden
eingeschlossen
die zahl der toten seit beginn der
brände ist auf zwölf gestiegen
in den südöstlichen bundesstaaten
victoria und new south wales flohen
einwohner und touristen vor den feuern
ans meer
florian kojak berichtet fahrt durch die
flammenhölle nur die scheiben ihres
trucks trennen die einsatzkräfte von dem
wütenden feuer und die drohen zu bersten
wegen der extremen hitze
die männer sind ausgerückt um zu helfen
und können dann mit viel glück nur ihr
eigenes leben retten
zu übermächtig sind die brände die sich
angefacht durch starken wind immer
weiter ausbreiten
viele ortschaften haben sie umzingelt
ihr vorbote dichter beißender rauch
anwohnern und touristen bleibt oft nur
noch ein ausweg die flucht zur küste
unser haus ist heute morgen
niedergebrannt also sind wir zum strand
um uns zu retten und wieder saubere luft
atmen zu können
es machte einfach keinen sinn das haus
zu verteidigen gedacht nur aus solange
wir noch können
tausende haben sich an dem rund 200
kilometer langen küstenabschnitt
versammelt qualm verdunkelte den himmel
es regnet asche notfalls sollen die
menschen ausgeflogen oder mit schiffen
über das meer in sicherheit gebracht
werden
niemand weiß wann sie zurückkehren
können und was von ihrem zuhause dann
noch übrig ist
denn in den kommenden tagen bleibt es
heiß trocken und windig das feuer wird
australien also auch im neuen jahr
weiter in atem halten ihn sozusagen
letzter minute haben sich russland und
die ukraine auf letzte details eines
neuen gas vertrags geeinigt wichtig vor
allem für den gastransit nach
deutschland das abkommen gilt für fünf
jahre und soll mögliche engpässe auch
weitere europäische staaten abwenden
die bisherige vereinbarung wäre heute
zum jahreswechsel ausgelaufen
der heutige silvestertag ist für
wladimir putin ein denkwürdiger auf den
tag genau vor 20 jahren wurde er
präsident von russland seitdem lenkt er
die geschicke des riesenreichs dabei
inszeniert sich der inzwischen
67-jährige immer wieder als starker und
sportlicher führer wirtschaftliche
aufschwung und außenpolitischer härte
brachten booten im voll große zustimmung
ein
doch zuletzt macht sich unzufriedenheit
breit
der druck auf den kremlchef wächst
kristiansand berichtet moskau macht sie
schön fürs neue jahr
die 20 steht heute in russland aber auch
für den blick zurück
es war die silvesternacht 1999 vor 20
jahren als der damalige präsident boris
jelzin überraschend zurücktrat
sein nachfolger wladimir putin seit zwei
jahrzehnten hat der ex kgb agent jetzt
die zügel der macht in der hand als
präsident und ministerpräsident mit
symbolträchtigen bildern untermauert er
gerne seine botschaft
wenn der starke mann russlands in allen
lebenslagen geliebt gehasst gefürchtet
und bewundert 2001 hatte putin im
bundestag noch für eine engere
zusammenarbeit mit deutschland geworben
heute müssen jedoch fest und endgültig
erklären
der kalte krieg ist vorbei putin
übernahm 1999 ein marodes land er sorgte
zunächst für wirtschaftlichen aufschwung
und brachte die gas und atom macht
russland zurück auf die weltbühne
selbstbewusst und stolz
doch die kritik an seiner autoritären
politik wurde immer lauter
die annexion der krim 2014 der syrien
krieg oppositionelle die ermordet oder
verhaftet werden
massenproteste für mehr demokratie
demonstranten die zusammengeschlagen
werden die wirtschaft schwächelt die
armut wächst auch das gehört heute zu
putins russland
wir müssen von niemandem in die knie
gehen ich bin stolz auf mein land und
auch putin
ich bin dafür dass regierungen wechseln
wenn man zu lange an der macht ist sieht
man viele sachen nicht mehr 2024 endet
offiziell putins amtszeit aber
spekuliert wird dass der 67-jährige die
verfassung ändern könnte um dann noch
länger an der macht zu bleiben
eine traurige nachricht für alle freunde
der opa harry kupfer einer der
wichtigsten und erfolgreichsten
regisseure ist gestorben
kupfer inszenierte klassische wagner
stücke in bayreuth fühlte sich aber auch
der moderne verpflichtet als
chefregisseur an der komischen oper in
ost berlin wurde er zu einem der
renommiertesten künstler der ddr
bis zuletzt war er auch im ausland tätig
und weltberühmt harry kupfer wurde 84
jahre alt
mit partys und feuerwerk heißen
milliarden menschen das neue jahr und
damit auch das neue jahrzehnt willkommen
2009 10 geht 2020 kommt bereits am
vormittag feierte der inselstaat samoa
den jahreswechsel um 14 uhr unserer zeit
knallten böller und raketen auf sydneys
berühmte hafenbrücke tobias häfner hat
die silvester eindrücke gesammelt und
beginnt beim australischen nachbarn in
neuseeland 321 neuseelands ureinwohner
die mauri zählen runter und dann sind
sie da die 20er jahre aus mehr als 200
metern höhe schießt in der metropole
auckland das erste großfeuerwerk des
globus in den griff
drei flugstunden weiter westlich in
sydney ist die stimmung trotz unter
bilder nicht bei allen unbeschwert im
board feuerwerk steckt nun mal feuer und
davon hat australien zur zeit
bekanntlich mehr als genug absage der
pompösen feier viele hatten das
gefordert doch die verantwortlichen
entschieden anders und so mischt sich
zum auftakt des jahres 2020 über harbour
bridge und opa sozusagen der geruch von
schwarzpulver mit dem der flächenbrände
zwei stunden später japan
dort nutzten viele menschen die später
stunde auch für etwas innere einkehr
die tempel überall im land gut besucht
und oft sehr stimmungsvoll mit klängen
aus schnecken hörnern oder dem anblick
von fackeln im schnee wie sydney kämpft
auch hongkong zu diesem jahreswechsel
mit problemen wenn auch ganz anderen die
angespannte politische lage lastet auf
der silvesterparty die show viel
spärlicher als sonst
sicherheitsbedenken sagen die behörden
touristen und einheimische müssen sich
mit einer lasershow begnügen aber das
immerhin vor einer der spektakulärsten
hochhaus kulissen der erde von asien
rollt das jahr 2020 nun in richtung
europa das neue jahrzehnt
es ist fast angekommen und die größte
silvesterparty der republik steigt
wieder in berlin am brandenburger tor
auf deutschlands bekanntester open air
party meile wird schon am frühen abend
kräftig eingeheizt
mit dabei unter anderem die schwedische
rock und pop band mando diao und auch
die musiker von karat dürfen im
jubiläumsjahr von 30 jahren mauerfall
natürlich nicht fehlen
sylvia bleßmann hat sich schon mal
umgesehen vorfreude auf die große party
trotz verstärkter kontrollen beim
einlass alle wollen feiern vor
geschichtsträchtiger kulisse mit viel
live-musik unter anderem vor den gipsy
kings hier bei der probe am nachmittag
erwartet werden hunderttausende berliner
und ihre gäste wir kommen aus hamburg
und bayern drei jahre hier in berlin wir
finden das toll die leute kommen aus der
ganzen welt um hier silvester zu feiern
das ist klasse ich bin italienerin und
feier in berlin
es ist großartig ich freue mich hier zu
sein wenn das neue jahr begrüßt wird
während auf der partymeile die knallerei
schon lange untersagt ist wird heute
auch an anderen orten wie zum beispiel
dem alexanderplatz das zünden von
feuerwerkskörpern verboten sein
mit 2.000 zusätzlichen beamten soll das
böllerverbot in berlin durchgesetzt
werden
die pyro verbotszonen verstärken jetzt
lediglich die verbote die ohnehin gelten
und sollen uns natürlich auch davor
schützen selber angegriffen zu werden
friedlich und fröhlich soll die
silvestersause werden
schon bei den proben am nachmittag tolle
stimmung und viele gute vorsätze für das
neue jahr 2020 anfang leben zu leben ja
mehr trainieren glücklicher sein und
sich weniger sorgen über kleinigkeiten
match wieder offener werden aufeinander
zugehen und mit einem lächeln durchs
leben wir in einer stunde überträgt das
zdf dann live die mega party am
brandenburger tor
und wie jedes jahr feiern für das zdf
andrea kiewel und johannes b kerner mit
auf der bühne vor dem brandenburger tor
hallo ihr 2 was habt ihr euch den
vorgenommen für heute abend
hallo liebe petra hannen guten abend sie
mit zuschauern berlin berlin es fühlt
sich so an als hätte diese statt 364
tage auf genau diese eine nackte wartet
stimmung johannes könnt ihr nicht mehr
leisten treben gute stimmung schon jetzt
viele hunderttausend menschen sind jetzt
schon da obwohl die eigentliche party
erst um 20 15 beginnt ist wirklich
unglaublich und für musik aus drei
jahrzehnten das allerbeste orleans she's
got bleiben comeback feiern und was muss
in der shadow einen super hilfen aus dem
vergangenen jahr 10 und 17 kämpfen
die kennt meine reist reichte bis hin
zur siegessäule johannes fischer fast
eine millionen ist damit voll und die
waadt nehmen man nun klar gesagt es ist
die größte silvester live party nicht
nur von deutschland sondern von europa
euro die ganze welt zu gast in berlin
und sie liebe zuschauer zu sorgen nein
wir bleiben dabei das motto party
zusammen ist man weniger allein
und es ist die einzige live show im
deutschen fernsehen danke euch auch sehr
schon eine menge los und viel spaß heute
abend und vor einer heißen feier eiskalt
baden das ist silvester tradition für
die abgehärteten in deutschland zb beim
verein brandenburger eisbären vor dem
rutsch ins neue jahr erstmals in die
havel rutschen die wassertemperatur am
gefrierpunkt sie stimmung nicht und
damit keine frost wollen gibt gilt auch
an land immer in bewegung bleiben
ja und sportlich geht's gleich weiter
will eine hoch hinaus karl geiger
avanciert zum überflieger bei der
vierschanzentournee nach platz zwei in
oberstdorf entschied er die
qualifikation von garmisch partenkirchen
für sich und will nun voll auf angriff
gehen denn er habe nichts zu verlieren
diesmal nimmt karl geiger die
glückwünsche von oberstdorf sieger rio
kobayashi entgegen und zwar als sieger
der qualifikation geigers sprung auf 139
meter bringt mehr als einen prestige
erfolg der zeigt dass der toni zweiter
auch die chance in
garmisch-partenkirchen im griff hat im
flug ist jetzt auch schon oberstadt
extrem gegangen und da habe ich als
gutes spiel momentan von dem er das
passt es und da der pflege weg das macht
was
sein wohl größter konkurrent der japaner
kobayashi betritt weiter in ansteigender
form der dreifache weltmeister markus
eisenbichler rang fünf beste stimmung
also bei den deutschen vor dem morgigen
neujahrsspringen tolles bild und das
zeigen wir morgen live in zdf sportextra
von 13 uhr 45 an
der frühere fußball nationalspieler
julian weigel steht vor einem wechsel
von borussia dortmund zu benfica
lissabon
allerdings muss der 24-jährige
mittelfeldspieler bei portugals
rekordmeister noch den medizin check
durchlaufen die höhe der ablösesumme
soll 20 millionen euro betragen
der musste nur ein und in london bei der
darts wm gibt es morgen abend die
neuauflage des endspiels von 2014 der
niederländer michael van gerwen trifft
auf den schotten peter wight beide
gewannen ihre halbfinals mit 6 zu 3
eine herausgestreckte zunge 1 2 knapp am
kopf vorbei und zum schluss nicht mal
ein handshake gegenseitige provokationen
dominierten das erste halbfinale
zwischen dem schotten wright und dem
waliser preis das duell bis zum sechsten
satz ausgeglichen 3 3 dann aber so breit
davon und entschied das halbfinale der
beiden streithähne mit 6 zu 3 für sich
dort trifft er auf seinen dauer rivalen
und den titelverteidiger michael von
raven der niederländer bezwang den
engländer espinel ebenfalls mit 6 zu 3
und könnte nun morgen abend zum vierten
mal weltmeister werden sagt eine frau
auch nicht schlecht muss ich sagen für
dieses jahr machen zwei mitgemacht ja ja
ja ja eben sehr erfolgreich und wie
beginnt das neue jahr zunächst neblig
später kommt dann die sonne raus gunther
tiersch hat gleich die einzelheiten so
viel von uns für dieses jahr wir danken
ihnen für ihr anhaltendes vertrauen in
unsere nachrichten und für ihre treue
und wünschen vom gesamten team der heute
guten rutsch bis morgen dann um 19 uhr
am 11 20 21
[Musik]
meine liebe zuschauer ruhiges wetter
begleitet uns ins neue jahr heute war es
ja herrlich sonnig einerseits in süden
der alpen zum beispiel mit herrchen
skiwetter zum beispiel oder auch eben an
den küsten sonnenschein zwischendrin
allerdings die wolken
die werden sich in den nächsten stunden
mehr und mehr auflösen so wird es erst
einmal klar um mitternacht nach der
böllerei wird es dann auch verbreitet
neblig bei den frostigen temperaturen
minus 1 bis minus 7 grad etwas milder
ist an den küsten aber david besonders
an der ostsee noch dieser starke
nordwestwind dazu morgen beginnt der tag
meist neblig trüb im süden kann hier und
da die sonne schon rauskommen und zum
nachmittag hin wird es im süden und in
der mitte freundlich mehr sonnenschein
im norden allerdings da haben wir wohl
den ganzen tag über den hochnebel und es
wird auch direkt an den küsten ein recht
kräftiger südwestwind dazu die
temperaturen verändern sich gegenüber
heute kaum es sind null bis sechs grad
am alpenrand vielleicht auch sieben grad
und in den nächsten tagen im neuen jahr
zum wochenende wird es unbeständig
nasskalt mit regen im flachland mit
schnee in den bergen und es wird sehr
windig jetzt wünsche ich ihnen einen
guten rutsch ins neue jahr und machen
sie es gut